uh we also want to just let you know
that one of the cameras on this episode
was a touch out of focus
so we just want to let you know that um
don't think there's something wrong with
your optics uh fortunately it was the
camera on me and you still get to see
shane gillis crystal clear enjoy the
show
we can do it you can do it
and we can do it together if we want um
i'm doing some shows and that is uh may
7th
i will be in los angeles we added a show
right in los angeles
here for the um
netflix is a joke festival that's at the
wilton
albuquerque may 18th midland
may 19th in texas lubbock texas may 20
dallas texas may 21 and a show has been
added there and selling well almost sold
out thank you guys so much for that
support
savannah georgia june 2nd augusta
georgia june 3rd montgomery alabama june
4th columbus georgia june 5th if you
have friends over there in georgia
you know people that have that love
georgia you tell them about it
hollywood florida june 23 fort myers
florida june 24th daytona beach and
lakeland june 25th and 26th
grab your tickets at theovonn.com
t-o-u-r that is the safest and best
place to get them thank you guys so much
in advance uh for your support and i
look forward to seeing you on the return
of the rat tour
today's guest is a very talented young
man and he's a
a great um
comedy man
and he uh so happy he's here today and
uh he has his own podcast called matt
and shane's
secret podcast he has a special live in
austin uh which has over four million
views on youtube happy to have him
return
to this past weekend
my friend mr shane gillis
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
shane gillis man your life you're you're
getting busy man i am busy
yeah i mean you're getting busy man do
you do do things start feeling a little
bit different because i feel like
you you're kind of becoming like the guy
you know thanks smith like the handsome
tim dill i am yeah i was gonna say yeah
the second part had to be because they
had so i was like wait what
uh like that tom selleck meets him like
yeah a little more yeah uh i don't know
i don't how did you feel when it
happened for you when it was when the
come up because it makes me
uncomfortable
yeah that's an interesting question man
i um
i don't think you know that it's really
happening to like it's happening
but it's i think the funny thing is more
of it's happening for other people in
some ways yeah yeah yeah because they're
all watching it yes
but um
the way you the way that i noticed it
started to seem for me was like
people would kind of stop me and i was
like oh this is interesting yeah
i don't know if i'm going to be able to
not be
seen in some types of sometimes now like
in some ways maybe yeah yeah and then
and then people started coming to the
shows and that was the part that's it
yeah yeah like uh occasionally like
occasionally i'll get a pop on an intro
and i'll be like oh [ __ ] like this is
new this is crazy
yeah oh yes oh daddy you know what
that's actually exactly first time yeah
first time i got one i did a guest spot
it was right after rogan the first time
i did a guest spot on tim dillon's show
yeah and it was like a surprise guest
and i got a pop and i was like oh what
the [ __ ] they're people this is crazy i
hate it yes that's good because the next
night i went i went back to philly and i
was i did a spot on the stephano's show
in philly which is where i'm from i was
like
i'm gonna get another pop yeah
dude
we got a guest guest spot for you uh
shane gillis i've walked out it was like
i was like damn i thought i had
something going
and it was just you clapping yeah just
like move
this guy's great yeah dude that's when
it is i think that's what it is you know
what that's really the perfect thing
it's like yeah it's like when you're
going on stage and you're like oh my
gosh there's people
like they'll say something you've said
before they'll yell out a term
um yeah we were doing a storytelling
show last night
and well two weeks ago and i uh
oh cause oh you were doing was that last
night that was it that was at the at the
nashville comedy festival at the wild
what is it west county no i think this
is nashville comedy festival at
nashville yeah at national comedy fan i
was at the ryman and it was a
storytelling show it was ari's show and
like two seconds into my set because i
was like opening with some material i
said two words i was like i like history
and this guy is like do a story i was
like dude you knew two words of my
material that's new
you psycho then he came up after he
looked like hell he was like that was me
that yelled that i was like you ruined
yeah don't give me a high five yeah why
do these people oh there's always that
guy who's like hey i was the guy that i
was one who [ __ ] yelled and ruined
your [ __ ] remember me there's always
that urchin he's like hey he like slides
up it's it's almost like this it's like
uh it's always some creepy i wish you
could see this dude like he looked like
a like a miner he looked like a 49er oh
yeah like beard like yeah i came up with
his bro we're fully decked out in
titan's gear everything tightens yeah
it's crazy dude it's crazy yeah titan's
conscious rose though for real good bro
it's definitely a tightness oh i bet he
had a tanny hill condom on
dude i bet uh
you know rob verona's hit a tree not far
from here he used to be a field goal
kicker yeah and he hit the upright rob
my baroness yeah and he hit a tree did
he how's he doing he tr he's he's gone
he's in heaven he died from a hitting a
tree he got heavened out yeah that'll do
it he hit that
wide right bro
damn yeah it's kind of terrible it's
like a lore around the national area
it's the lore that's where rob baroness
hit a tree yeah and they even have his
initials on the tree too really still um
what was i gonna say oh yeah dude so
it's yeah you're you're you're just
this is kind of it
you know where you get busy and then you
can sell tickets and i think that's the
amazing thing is that people want to
come see you it's like
because you
it's almost weird with comedy you get
going in it and you're just doing it and
it becomes just about the comedy
and then you realize wow people want to
come see me yeah like there's something
about me that they sometimes it's not
the comedy i think especially with
podcasters and um and especially with
your story kind of like being like
uh
you know there's a whole [ __ ] snl type
of energy out there in the world anyway
yeah and i think that you add that with
your your
you know just being insanely funny and
then it's like oh i want to go see this
guy and then people with podcasts they
like the person they want to see the
person yeah yeah it's it's yeah it's
crazy
yeah it happened pretty quick yeah so
like because of no tickets forever and
then all of a sudden people want to show
up and like ah yeah like if they yell
your dad's name out you're like all
right take it easy ronnie's chill chill
chill it's ronnie's song i'm trying to
do stand up yeah this isn't the podcast
yeah it's fun though
do you think sometimes people don't know
when they come if it's going to be like
the podcast or if it's different i i
find that sometimes i find that some
people are like oh i thought the
sometimes after the show somebody's like
man i thought it was going to be like
the podcast you know and i almost feel
bad i'm like dang you know i'm sorry
yeah i wish i could make it is good yeah
stand up podcasts are funny
stand up is me doing something yeah like
doing my little art yeah
but man yeah congrats on everything dude
it's awesome it's funny because i even
look at you and i even get like just gel
i'm like oh the because the funnest
thing is when you when people are
getting to like
getting to know you you know yeah and i
i mean obviously i still have a ton of
people getting to know me i'm not saying
like i've made it or nothing but
you could you could say that yeah like
you stay busy enough you know but the
funnest part is yeah when people are
like oh shane gill if you're the shane
gillis i wonder if that's because that's
how i feel about like my buddy some of
my friends are still doing like open
mics and hanging out in philly and i'm
like damn that was the best oh yeah like
now i wonder if you're just having the
same thing where you're like no the best
was when it started
oh yeah this is the best i'm gonna be
sad yeah
because if this only gets worse from
here i'm already pretty bummed out yeah
yeah that's true that's not doing great
that's
that could be something that could be
something
so dude so because you grew up in the uh
and pennsylvania man you grew up out and
were you like an amish country do you
ever have any interaction with the
audience there's a lot of hummus around
wow yeah lancaster that's i i was like
30 40 minutes west of amish country but
they're around dude did you ever get
approached by him because i could see
you being
like i definitely if i'm amish and i'm a
you know i don't want to say a milk
drinker yeah yeah but if i'm somebody
that's close to that udder maybe i'll
just get milk yeah yeah he saw me yeah
that guy's chugging milk obviously
like uh that guy's eight percent right
there yeah they uh no but you'll see him
we usually yell at him when we're kids
what we gotta say like like nice [ __ ]
horse dumbass
get a car you [ __ ] idiot
you drive past him
it was fun now i look back on him like
that's very inappropriate the crazy part
is people that yell out like queers
these aren't gay people still that's i
mean they're gay for women
and i don't stand for it yeah that's
funny yeah driving by an amish dude and
a buggy be like [ __ ] homo
he's gonna be like what the [ __ ] oh dude
a couple black dudes called me the n
word a couple months ago dude and it was
like that kind of brightens your day a
little i felt
you know i was like you promised you
know i didn't know what to say that's so
cool thank you guys i'll like say it
again man it's cool when you guys did
yeah we like it
i remember when i was young somebody was
throwing rock me and my buddy were
fishing it was a black friend of mine
who's i think in jail for murder now man
my friend devin but
he um
he
uh
we're fishing in some white some racist
white dude or some somebody racist who
looked white from where we were was up
on these train tracks starts throwing
rocks at us
and yelling the n word right and so i
jump out and i'm like not me dude i'm
saying like at least
yeah don't get me you're getting the
wrong guy you're gonna hit me with a
rock
but that [ __ ] was wild dude the amish
every once in a while get smoked by like
trucks
dude they're driving horse horse and
buggies
the truck truck driver will go wide
right and just splatter them rob around
horses and [ __ ]
it's bad really and they hit him and i
guess uh oh
would you rather get hit from the back
with a trucker from the front
like definitely from
behind boss
definitely i don't want to see that
thing coming dude you don't i don't want
to have one set i don't want to have one
second to be like oh
here it comes i just want to
just fade to black just
that'd be
nice oh what sound would you make that's
not how i think about that
wait am i in a car or i'm just getting
no you're just walking you're out there
walking something's not going good yeah
right yeah yeah something's gone wrong
yeah something is wrong i'm walking out
there and i'm walking and uh yeah i
definitely want it to be from behind
yeah i don't dude because if you see it
coming your last you know you're gonna
be trying to get out of the way for the
last second that's gonna be your last
thing you do and the saddest part if one
of your friends saw you because you'd
probably put your hands up like yeah he
put his hands up to try to stop it
like you see that idiot he's a fire
truck hit him he put his hands up yeah
you would do you of course you would
yeah that would be tough man it'd be
tough to figure that out so was there a
lot was there amish people like in your
like was it a was there like would you
all go to any amish markets i'm just
trying to wonder some of these amish
markets and [ __ ]
i didn't really go to those but they
have uh we have like mennonite kids in
our school wow yeah
chick that would wear like a bonnet yeah
they were like
because there's there's there's levels
to amish and there's mennonites that i
don't think follow like the no
electricity and [ __ ] but they'll like
drive the only color their car can be is
black
they can drive it like twice a week or
some crazy [ __ ] oh really yeah oh damn
they're not all like strict no
electricity know this yeah
oh dang so they got some like batman
mennonite kind of yeah there's a lot of
those guys
damn
i didn't realize that
they're flying they're out there
yeah we tried i know we tried for a
while to get a real amish or uh somebody
semi-amish on here and we couldn't do it
i was at a i was at a football game in
indiana there's a lot of them in indiana
and ohio too and they uh these dudes
were just on rump springer
[ __ ] tailgating with us wow and they
were getting wrecked dude damn they were
jacked from all the [ __ ] work oh
you're just getting ham just idiots
they're dumped oh they could build a
birdhouse with their tongue
the amish they'll build a damn
they would like and they speak with a
crazy accent really i can't even do it i
don't know they call us the english
oh wow yeah
i didn't know that so they don't look at
so do they look at themselves as even
like
i mean i guess they look at themselves
as human yeah for sure and they look at
themselves as religious but they don't
look at themselves as like
english or anything no they think we're
the english and they're the i don't know
what the [ __ ] they are germans damn yeah
they're wrong yeah
that's wrong across the board
and where some of the women did y'all
see some of them um
nice babe it's rare but if you if you
see a hot amish chick it's like damn
that's good that's that's my queen yeah
it's in a beautiful flowery dress
yeah no one's touched her oh what a
sweet angel
stinks like hell
you think they smell good or bad no they
smell bad oh yeah they do smell bad i
hope that well yeah they're not going to
care oh yeah
they don't smell great yeah there's
something kind of room i feel like
there's some sense of romance about it
um yeah for sure cause you i think you
always romanticize like a woman with a
pail of water and you know and you you
can help her hey i'll be you know yeah
let me help you i'll build us a boat or
something you know like i feel like
and you can almost you could use
anything to get some excitement you
could be like hey let's you know have
you ever done this and you just do like
the dougie form or something you know
you just do like something like have you
ever done the soldier boy you just do
something like that just yeah you do
something crazy they've never seen yeah
yeah yeah they've never even seen
[Laughter]
you're incredible this is gonna be yeah
[Laughter]
i just think some of the ways you could
hit on amish women would be insane dude
for sure or if you did this thing you
know like oh
yeah they might burn you yeah yeah they
might burn you you might get literally
soldier boy they might burn you they
might be like dude that's witchcraft
we're not having that here
imagine how peaceful you think it's
peace will be an amish on the inside of
them or you think it's i don't know
that's the thing like you were saying it
might be great yeah just [ __ ] working
doing real work like farm work building
[ __ ] and then you go to sleep oh
yeah i don't know and you don't no one
around you is [ __ ] doing good yeah so
that helps oh but not on instagram no
you're not so you're not you but i
wonder if there's an intense fear of
missing out because you're seeing you
see one car go by and some you know
there's a little
you know there's someone a woman with a
bathing suit you've got to lose your
mind
yeah
if you're just sitting behind a horse
going [ __ ] four miles an hour down
that [ __ ] highway
convertible flies by and something you
just smell like last you hear one second
of cool music
yes what the [ __ ] was that yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] dude and yeah and dad's
like get your eyes back in your head
samuel
why are we doing this this sucks
it must feel like you're on the most
insane halloween ever i feel like it's i
mean yeah if you ever get and they do
rum spring it and that's as long as you
want it's not like one year some of them
stay out
for like 10 years have a regular life
and then they're like
back to amish
guys i gotta let y'all know he's going
back yeah i'm breaking probably [ __ ]
sick you just burn out in real life you
just go so hard go as hard as you can
get addicted to [ __ ] yeah then you're
like dude i'm going back back to the
farm i bet when you roll back in there
though i bet people are coming up and
smelling your breath and wanting to
touch you
like what was it what was it like yeah
i've been doing coach edward was at rum
spring look at him i've been doing
cocaine yeah it's crazy
you know how much we get done around
here
yeah oh that's fascinating man see i
wish we didn't have nothing like that
growing up dude we grew up actually uh
they had like an adult store near us
sometimes and sometimes they would throw
like boxes of stuff that was like
defunct in the woods
and so we'd be back there people would
come back with all kind of sex toys and
[ __ ] with pine needles and stuff on them
but we didn't that was we didn't have
anything like and we had black people
white people
but we didn't get any
almost mythological creatures when you
go you know what i'm saying it's a real
pull up amis brother
can you pull up a uh
land dutch i think they call them as
well
they are yeah it is just a different
they're just doing a different time
period for no reason
which is it's just unbelievable it's 18
20. it's like right why
yeah oh it's beautiful
now see the lancaster is beautiful
though that that like area where they're
at oh yeah it's awesome well then also i
wonder what happens if they see the
horses having sex does that set you know
is that an awkward time for everybody i
wonder i bet they don't give i don't
think they i think they're like great
more horses
oh yeah i think they're yeah they're not
thinking of it like that's like pulling
not like dude he's [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of that horse
that's awesome
i wish i could do that
yeah it's not like mardi gras new
orleans you see there's a video of marty
garner's like there's a cop on a
horseback and another coffin and one one
horse
which i think is the gayest thing it's
almost bestiality too if you're riding
shotgun on a horse [ __ ]
[Laughter]
who are you
you notice god still know you that's the
part that really gets me
um what was that time period we actually
had a question that came in about a time
period was this it
that's beautiful yeah let's go with it
shane theo what's up it's jesse boone
coming to you from atmore alabama
love both y'all love both y'all's
content love uh love both y'all specials
but podcasts keep it up fellas i love it
shane i'm a history nerd get the sense
that you're a bit of a historian got a
question for you two questions really
one
what's your favorite
period of history to read about or
listen to a podcast about
two
when and why haven't you started
a
rip-off of the old history of hyenas a
la chrissy chaos and yanis yani papi
love you guys gang gang
gang baby thank you brother for the
question mr boone there
yeah i mean world war ii is the easy one
is it that's the cool one everybody
likes that one and is that the one who
were they killing in that was that jews
or not
it was yeah yeah i didn't i got they
killed everybody though oh they did but
they got they got it pretty bad yeah you
know what i mean they got jade out yeah
yeah that was a rough one for them they
would they don't like that stuff
yeah oh trust me every book at the
airport's about it yeah i get it
um yeah and yeah i i i feel that um
i like the civil war though the american
civil war i love it
yeah bro you ever go to the nashville
battlefield here dude we used to do when
i was growing up we could do cwrs all
the time man really yeah oh we'd be at
him man we got to be the uh we got to do
the drum a few times what else i got to
be like a
soldier's ceo cwr's constantly do you
really yeah i don't know because of
lancaster i was in gettysburg i grew up
right next to gettysburg yeah dude the
reenactments were [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
we should have [ __ ] won
what now you guys you guys stunk dude
we [ __ ] you guys up when we took the
gloves off the north just rained down on
them dude but well you know where we
[ __ ] up is we kept a lot of the
brothers out of the fight yeah
obviously
obviously if we had a plan to get i
think it did you know get a little bit
more
gets a bit more urban yeah we kept it
way too i think honkied out yes
yeah towards the end the the union was
like
get the brothers in also yeah [ __ ]
started
got bad but you guys had a lot of uh
i don't know why you guys won i guess we
we probably had some disorganization i
bet and i think you guys the the south
was much better
the generals were better yeah it was
organized but like lee and [ __ ]
stonewall jackson and long street those
guys were beasts yeah that's why they
were even in the fight was because of
how good they were oh wow because the
union outnumbered them more and more
industry more guns but they just didn't
have that streets they didn't have that
uh they posted smarts they had [ __ ]
in general yeah allegedly i don't want
to besmirch these guys but i could say
probably maybe they had some real nerds
up there yeah i could see that they had
nerds they had they were all well they
were all west point guys but they were
all
like uh like there's a guy named
mcclellan
oh yeah george yeah you just won an
attack yeah they're like you gotta go
lincoln was like go dude people in the
woods are yelling boom
oh that's cool
sherman and grant dude sherman came down
and gave you guys what for he got
[ __ ] lucky pulled up a picture of
sherman on mr sherman civil war he's the
man
let's get a look at him
i have his picture hanging in my house
he really got sherman and grant and
custard
oh george custer yeah and he was the one
dating indians as well i think that's
the one with his arms crossed crazy hair
a lot of diy man a lot of dating indians
yourself you know they had a lot of
those dudes out there
a lot of them you know dipping in the
corn meal if you don't think you are
brother bro what would you be doing i
mean just get done committing a human
you just get done committing an atrocity
you're not going to want to have some
sex
yeah
at this point you've done you're you're
done right you're done you've sold your
soul you are evil that's a good let's go
once you go evil you then you're [ __ ]
then you're in evil it's like normally i
wouldn't just grab this lady yeah but
but i did just kill a family yeah you're
right damn it's time to go that's crazy
once you go full evil you're full evil i
didn't really i never really thought
about that
you know we had a guy that lived across
youth from us named brad and i think he
killed his mother
who was our
favorite lunch lady annie
dude and we loved her dude and she like
her one of her hands shook her both of
them shook
and she would like get the food and it
was just your whole town
oh bro it was such a risky
waiting for the food to get to your
plate it was like one of those guys that
used to drive the dynamite trucks back
in the day you know on the on the rocky
roads it was just unbelievable really
and then the grandson came like
he got sick of it well he uh
i think they thought that if they killed
her if she was gonna get they were gonna
get the apartment
and they didn't get it the landlord kept
it uh somebody else
was like that's not how this works dude
yeah dude just bad punches in [ __ ]
medieval times yeah it was just a lot of
kill him it'd be the heir to this
apartment yeah just bad organization man
but yeah dude i can't believe that the
civil war would have been insane dude i
have had these dreams where i go like
undercover boss into like
i don't want to say slavery but like i'm
like an undercover boss like in a like
amongst like a slaves you know slave
group or something i don't know what
they
like i don't know what the correct term
is
you know but um
i always have these dreams where i go
undercover all that show undercover boss
or something like that yeah you know
oh okay yes i get it sorry it took me a
while i was just worried about where
this was going yeah so you're saying you
would want to be a
plantation owner that's like undercover
bosses
no i'm not saying anything like that
okay what i'm saying
it'd be uncomfortable
no i'm saying i have had dreams where i
go undercover boss
in like uh and i'm like a foreman at
like a
uh
like a like a
i don't call it like a like a during
slave times
yes yes and what are you saying so that
would be a plantation
yes okay yeah so you would want to be
the boss of the plantation no i don't
want to be but then how could you be the
undercover boss because i'm having
dreams where you do undercover bossing
where they like send the boss to work at
the plantation i get it right okay do
you want to be the undercover boss or
you're just dreaming it up
no no it's not a dream it's not like in
my uh
you know like wrote it down
you woke up like that that was a great
idea dude i'm gonna get this done
it's not on a vision board yeah it is
just i have operations in my head while
i'm resting yeah you know i'm talking
about nighttime dreams yes so you want
the
owner of slaves to and how would he be
undercover what would he have to do
no you're on a suddenly undercover i
just keep in the dream i'm undercover
and i'm like oh what do you guys want to
do today you know but i'm seeing if
anybody wants to sneak out or escape so
it's like i'm doing it like for bad
reasons yeah i'm like secret shopper
you know what i'm talking about you know
i'm talking about secret shopper where
people come in and they order the food
but they're not really there to eat
they're
they're sneaking around for somebody
sure yeah
but
anyway you were going down there to
check on morale and be like how's
everybody doing oh yeah annoying you
were going down to be like any
[ __ ] trying to leave
that look
this is bad
let's just order that nazi pizza
right here this isn't good man
if you run an e-commerce business or you
do e-commercing
then you probably feel like it's about
time people stop treating
the e-commerce giants better just
because they're bigger
and you're absolutely right
you are
that's why shipstation gives e-commerce
sellers of all sizes access to the same
deeply discounted rates usually reserved
for fortune 500 companies yup ship
station you'll be competing with the big
boys you get deeply discounted rates
it works with over 45 carriers
you can easily compare rates and
delivery times to quickly find the best
option every time through ship station
works with over 300 platforms like
amazon ebay and etsy
yep to automate processes like
fulfillment and tracking
in fact 98 percent of companies that use
shipstation for a year keep using it as
long as they're in business
sign up now using promo code t-h-e-o
that's that code you need it for a free
60-day trial
at
shipstation.com and start saving with
every shipment that's two whole months
of discounted shipping
absolutely free just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in
t-h-e-o ship station make ship happen
for most of us uh
a lot of people can't talk can't even
speak well you see somebody and
you ask them something they don't know
and they do know but they can't even
they just kind of do um
what's it called um
when you play that they do uh charades
you know they'll tell you what do you
want for lunch and they're sitting there
acting out a you know a sandwich or a
tomato based suit
well
learning a second language
isn't always easy
now thanks to babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions there's an
actively fun and easy way to learn a new
language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family
or you just have some free time
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons you'll actually use in the real
world now that is good
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a language on the
go
yep that's it
there are so many ways to learn with
babel
plus it comes with a 20 day money back
guarantee start your new language
journey learning journey today
that's true
uh right now you can save up to 60 off
your subscription when you go to b a b b
e l
dot com slash theo
that's b a b b e l dot com slash theo
babble
com theo for up to 60 off your
subscription
babble language for life
here's a young man and this guy seems
like he has a lot of problems let's get
a question from him
hey what's up shane it's austin calling
from denver
just want to know
who's the bigger patriot you or theo
let me know
gang babe well i think with historical
accuracy it's obviously you i mean you
know more even about civil war
reenactments and stuff like that
i don't know i'm kind of i don't know i
don't know enough about your patriotism
i believe that
i like tradition
you know that's where i'm at you know so
i really like tradition i like i think
tradition is important to keep
a country a country yeah so i think a
lot of our tradition gets killed off
these days by
by people that are [ __ ] lames
yes
so i think yeah i sounded honestly that
sounded more patriotic than anything i
would ever say so really yeah
like i would even do i remember
sometimes i would do the uh pledge of
allegiance like this oh [ __ ]
that's crazy i had a kid i remember in
high school my buddy would sit down
during the national anthem a guy i knew
white chubby white kid
every day i'm like get up
yeah you know i was so mad that it was
so mad
i was a kid though i was like you better
stand up i just saw saving private ryan
yeah it's my i love the sniper in that
movie get up
yeah i think it was like i mean i like i
don't know i guess i'm just also i grew
up with a lot of traditions so you you
know you kind of get used to that stuff
and you think it's important yeah you
know um and it keeps people associated
with one another it's like you can
relate to other
uh
generations because you have similar
things that you've all done you know
yeah but
i don't know i mean to me that kind of
stuff's real pretty important but i
don't know who could be a real patriot
but my favorite movie is the patriot
next to um a league of their own
so
yeah
i love that i've seen two people i was
this is crazy i had two flights i had a
connecting flight on the first flight i
fell asleep the guy in front of me was
watching a league of their own the
second flight i i like came up from
another nap and the dude was watching
league of their own and i was like
is this the same flight
i was like did i dream
who's watching that yeah it's a great
film yeah maybe me or people that like
to also maybe listen to this show but i
remember my sisters rented that yeah and
when i was a little kid and it came in
the white case remember [ __ ] this movie
i don't want to watch this movie it's
[ __ ] girls it's stupid yeah and then
i watched it i was like [ __ ] nice
dude yeah look at their own rules
dude we went to the rockford illinois
recently did a show there and got to go
to the town and go to the museum
and see like all the old equipment and
attire and stuff really it's pretty cool
i believe there's one woman left can you
see is there anybody still alive from um
rockford peaches championship rockford
peaches championship yeah i always want
to see if anybody's still living from it
because they had one lady and they kept
wheeling her out at the vents and it was
getting dicey it was like it got rough
though dude some of the last pictures
she just had like a bake sale and bro i
don't even know if she's alive dude and
there's just there somebody's playing
like a radio it's like we are members of
to y'all
she just bro there's nothing left in the
tank what you got there bubby
margaret wig
wigglezer
a peach
oh january 2019 the last living local
rockford peaches oh or helen waddle
who's had some health scares
but at her 90th birthday and angie
argamatto wow
dang
that's crazy well your name is one
letter short of anger it's amge they
spell it um
how did you know you were funny when you
were young did you know you were funny
what was going on with you uh yeah i
didn't i i knew i was funny i was kind
of a [ __ ] growing up yeah school and
[ __ ] yeah i always had fun
making fun of people oh yeah talking
[ __ ] when you're young that's the best
way i loved it yeah yelling yeah class
school what's what's better than being
funny in school
farting in class
i never you did it oh i used to yes wow
and dude my one buddy used to fart yeah
he used to really do it and he would
come up to you and be like there's a
funny joke he would he would walk up to
you and go who do you want me to pass
this gas to
and you go you'd pick someone and he
would walk up to their desk
fart on the desk
how fun is that dude he used to [ __ ]
differently uh-huh in high school he
would [ __ ] diff he would come up a
different way to take a [ __ ] and me and
all my friends would come in and watch
him like sometimes he would hold himself
up from the top of the stalls
and drop it in oh yeah plank at the top
with his ass down
oh yeah
we got trouble with dj gaming it was
like what the [ __ ] is going on
he was holding himself up his face was
dark red because it was so hard to do
dude it was hard to do so hard you would
drop like one drop out we'd be like yo
people were screaming a math teacher
came in i was like what the [ __ ] are you
guys doing get out of here we on the run
you're like divide this
there is something amazing [ __ ] is like
such magic because it's like you can
just make [ __ ] come out of your body
it's almost like doing magic you know i
i bet the first time nobody had ever
seen it somebody it was like had just
opened their eyes and had never eaten
and then one guy would already eat and
rolled up and he's like hey watch this
like that's insane
yeah but that was really pretty pretty
kid yeah when you're young you're like
fascinated with it
i remember like you watch animals [ __ ]
you're looking around you're like damn
shitting's crazy everyone's [ __ ]
yeah yeah i would watch myself [ __ ] i
would i remember sticking my head
like as a kid trying to watch and really
seeing yeah yes poop's coming out of
your body i mean the fact that
something's leaving your body that you
didn't
because i remember first when i was
young i got so scared because i didn't
remember eating poop i didn't know how
it worked
and i was like oh my god dude i didn't i
didn't maybe i've been eating this in my
sleep yeah i was like have i've been
eating this in my sleep
you know [ __ ] outdoors
yeah it's a tough one i've never done it
you never [ __ ] it out never [ __ ]
outdoors my buddies have it i hate it
are you hating anytime i've been around
it it's just the worst
it's the worst
well it smells so [ __ ] bad out of
water
out of water yeah oh i see what you're
saying not in a toilet a dump is
catastrophic
yeah i think it kind of depends on where
you do it and how you do it cause i got
a feeling you've [ __ ] outside a lot
oh well dude when i was young you had
this kid in our town named mario
and uh
and he died actually he drove his boat
into an embankment which is insane and
r.i.p man i feel so sorry for him his
mother was a librarian and
beautiful guy he was italian i think or
semi-italian yeah and he would uh
defecate in his yard and i was younger
than him and for us to be friends i've
told the story he'd make me bury the
poops
and so i was always over there
you know shoveling around and his yard
had a lot of silt i think it was like
alluvial soil okay
so i was always over there you know
moving you know and sometimes you get
too many in one area they make you move
them to another area you gotta move the
bodies oh like i'm john wayne
or something like
oh that was a nightmare and then uh
that's a good friend like how did he how
did he talk you into that or dude oh he
he's one of those kids that didn't even
blink he was just had just like sheer
electricity going i need you to come
over to my house yeah well if he's like
if you want to hang out here you're
going to do this
and i was a kid you know so i remember
getting a lot of looks at you know
at that kind of work
and uh yeah you could judge for that
yeah but myself i did mount kilimanjaro
one time with a buddy and i remember
um for an extra 150 bucks they'll the
sherpas that go with you will build you
a little duty tent because otherwise you
gotta just defecate in the wild you know
yeah and there's other things [ __ ]
out there you know there's a lot of
animals out there you're in africa yeah
so there's you know it's weird when
you're out there [ __ ] and you can feel
other things [ __ ] in the distance it
makes you
it's got a real
royal rumble type of vibe you know
something out there you're not the only
one in the ring you know
and
and so i remember being up there for an
extra 150 bucks they'll build you that
little you know they'll get you
yeah that just little duty domicile you
know they'll really
uh construction you up a little a little
[ __ ] hostile
and so yeah we did it and thankfully
we're able to go in there you know but
uh but there was a couple times where we
couldn't and um and we would do it out
outdoors out on a mountain yeah kind of
nice
um
but yeah i guess that school lunch table
was the most fun there was nothing more
fun do you have to go to church than
that time sometimes yeah i went to
catholic school so we always had to go
to church those a fart in church
is
i'd have to leave
if i heard someone fart i'd be like i'm
so sorry everybody i'll never stop
laughing
because then the rest of the time it's
quiet so the only thing you can hear is
that burnt off the pew from from across
the room just to burn down yeah you hear
it i'm just like oh no
i have to leave i have to leave
yeah wow yeah something like that was so
magnificent why this one fell in our
class he would always walk we had this
chalkboard that was close to the wall
and he would always
walk back behind there and people would
forget that he was back there he'd stay
back there for a few minutes and then he
would just fart
so loud like the class would carry on
it'd be eight minutes later the teacher
would be giving and he would you'd
forget
it was such a it was trapped in this
little sound space it was just
surprising a room with a fart they
didn't know you were there it's [ __ ]
hilarious that's genuinely because you'd
startle a teacher an adult would be like
is somebody back there yeah farting yeah
somebody behind who's back there
somebody else who's back there who's
dumb grin on your face
and you're like i don't know what
happened i don't know what that was
high school if you're young enough and
you don't give a [ __ ] about high if you
or if you're if you're in high school
and you don't give a [ __ ] about it
really and you're kind of smart enough
to get unstoppable you're honest you can
do anything because the teachers know
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
yeah yeah because they barely finished
it and all they're doing now is teaching
it yeah yeah
i wish i always wish i could go back
and just be like dude yeah i promise it
doesn't matter yeah go why
go [ __ ] nuts here
because i was so afraid because my you
know i'd get like hit
you know by my dad if i like [ __ ] up
oh wow really yeah not like not if for
me it was hard but
he wasn't like beating me but it was
like that was always like if i got like
a detention or something like that yeah
i was like [ __ ] my parents are gonna
[ __ ] me up for this damn you know yeah
like i didn't care about the teachers
or school yeah i was like there is a
looming
physical punishment for this fart damn
yeah
so you had a little there was some skin
in the game you really want it yeah i
got i actually got the belt once because
my friend the same guy i've been talking
about this whole time dusty he farted we
were doing stations of the cross yeah
which
they just go around talk about each
thing jesus did on the way to getting
crucified
and so it's like it's pretty serious and
everybody's very quiet oh yeah it's like
the first 48. yeah and he farted so
[ __ ] loud and i i was i just exploded
i was i was crying and my teacher kicked
me out and i tried to defend myself and
i was like dusty farted
and she was like that's two you're
suspended
and i was like i'm gonna i started
crying outside i was like i'm gonna get
my [ __ ] ass
i got home my dad i remember like it was
yesterday my dad was cutting the cutting
the lawn in the back and i just walked
out and stood on her back porch and held
up the
pink slip
he just let go of the mower and it
turned off and he walked in
i ran to my room and he was walking up
the steps slapping the belt dude
yeah that's awesome and i was like he
didn't even hit me really he was just
like it scared the [ __ ] out of me damn
he was terrifying
it is kind of he's a good guy he's a
good guy he sounds like a good guy look
i think you got to beat your kid a
little you know whatever or spank i mean
if you didn't like hit me hard with the
belt that would be [ __ ] wild when you
also think about what a dad could really
do like right now you could have a seven
year old or something right yeah [ __ ]
him if you really wanted to you could
yeah
annihilate his heavier with a belt do
like a fatality yeah you could like take
his arms off
yeah goro just
like a wishbone oh what'd you get oh
yeah you do that to a kid damn that's
insane man here's a guy right here he
seemed like a pretty safe guy and uh
he's got a question for us but i would
say yeah let's
let's answer that fellas question the
toughest time to be or a time i would
really enjoy
civil war would be so
civil war would be so like
i would be grueling i wouldn't want to
live in any other time right now is the
only time you think maybe the last like
30 years
but yeah
what about maybe like the 70s you think
yeah 70s could be i think 70s might suck
dick let us be lovers i don't know there
was real big org
orgies yeah i'm not an orgy guy at all
oh you'd be the [ __ ] place where do
you beat up but you're the tall guy
i don't want to be near any of that
stuff yeah i i think i if i was back if
you have a camel back on
dude if i was back then i'd know i'd be
one of the dudes i was like [ __ ]
hippies
vietnam is good
like i'd be i know that's who i did the
calf slicer baby
that peruvian necktie the banana split
the hard scarf
there are tons of ways to come out on
top in the octagon
and for ufc 274 there's one more
with draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of ufc
new customers can bet five dollars on
any fighter
and win 150 in free bets if they do
that's right choose your fighter sit
back and watch the action unfold it's
going to be quite a night bet 5 and get
150 in free bets if your fighter wins
download the draftkings sportsbook app
now use promo code theo
throw down five buck arrows
on any ufc 274 fighter to win it
and get 150 and free bets of video
that's code theo this saturday at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of ufc minimum
age and eligibility restrictions
apply see
show notes for details
look the bottom line is people are
people are without hair
you see them all the time will smith's
husband
he lost it
and there's only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both that's right
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home that's keeps
they do it for you
low cost treatments start at just 10
bucks per month
and keeps offers generic versions of the
two fda approved medications to prevent
hair loss
treatment plans are affordable typically
half the cost of pharmacy prices wow
keeps has everything that your hair
needs delivered straight to your door
with discreet packaging and proven
results
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot
com theo to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com
slash t-h-e-o to get your first month
free keeps.com slash theo
hey shannon theo this is uh colton
coming at you from kearney nebraska i
was wondering who do you guys think
would win in a cage fight with you two
against each other maybe to the death um
maybe just the first one to get penned i
don't know it's up to you guys uh
anyways gang gang
i think you would probably uh rewire
i think we it'd be a good fight yeah
yeah it's an interesting thing to do to
a guest on a podcast
yeah i gotta have a guy i'll be like oh
let's take some questions yeah do you
think you could beat me up dude
that's true sorry don't [ __ ] yeah i
didn't think about that sorry man no
it's totally fine uh and i didn't even
know we're gonna have this question
actually i think uh i don't know again
same thing with the patriotism i've
never seen you
in action yeah yeah but i've got
probably a hundred pounds on you so
that'd help or hurt that's a good point
yeah it could be interesting i think
it'd be a good match i think so too yeah
that's cool
um yeah i'm trying to think if there was
anything else that was super
like we would go spend time like i'm
just trying to think of times that were
really really funny when you were young
like what was the most well once things
once girls come into the picture some of
the fun starts it's still there but it
changes then it's about being cool yeah
there's a certain level of coolness that
kind of comes in there as well there's a
lot of fun being mean to your friend
who's trying to be cool yeah that's fun
like when you see a kid trying to pick
up a girl yeah it's very fun to be like
yeah you're gay yeah for trying to do
that
yeah i'm trying to take a thing other
things that were great when i was young
i mean so much of it was fun field trips
bro when you were going field trips nuts
it was nuts yeah just on the bus on the
way to the zoo yeah with your bros oh
and girls that was when it was nice when
you started getting horny yeah and then
you'd go on a field trip and you'd be
like nice i'm sitting with the girl yeah
yes this is so cool we're gonna kiss oh
you're like damn melissa's sitting with
shane that's like crazy crazy yeah how'd
that even happen would it come up to
yeah and you're like damn he's really
changing i guess and then other guys
would feel so defeated you're like i'm
still sitting here with freaking marcus
yeah you know this dude's ugly yeah but
they would have more fun actually no i
would have a that was so fun when you
started dating for the first time in
your life like yeah that [ __ ] ruled
now it sucks i'd rather hang out with
the bros yeah i definitely was on a
field trip i would hate if i was sitting
with my [ __ ] girlfriend oh
yeah that's true huh
it is interesting yeah you go through
these phases where it's like one is kind
of better than the other when you're
really horned out bro when you got your
hormones rolling in your body
damn man them [ __ ] yeah i can't
believe it yeah you can't believe this
is this is so sick yeah holding hands on
a slow dance bro when your teacher would
come over and lean over to tell you
something you would see an edge of a
[ __ ] tit we had these weird i would
almost throw my dick off of my body it
was crazy i couldn't handle the pressure
we had a a lady that was like 70. she's
like seven years old huge tits oh great
tits but
looking back at it it's like damn that's
crazy i was horny for that lady every
day for like four years
every day i just stare at this lady's
old giant tits
yes
yeah and teachers would try to dress as
unseductive as possible
even oh dude give me that yeah i need to
see that yeah i want that b minus t i
don't mind that i like a good totally
covered woman yeah that makes me even
more horny see that's why i could really
see you i could almost see you look like
an attractive amish woman if you had the
bonnet on and the full regal like
[ __ ] rosie o'donnell in league of
their own oh damn dude you know who just
messaged me the other day was roseanne
barr hit me up and sent me a d
yeah i texted her i don't think she
texted me back actually
i wish she would i used to want to tour
with her it'd be awesome so cool that
would be cool
she was so cool man
um
yes so now are you moving into theaters
in some spaces do you like that i
haven't i haven't headlined a theater
really
actually at all yet yeah um that's i
think that's gonna start next year wow
we're working on that right now yeah
actually this year i'm doing some
theaters in england
and ireland oh wait i saw that you're
going to the shepherds actually yeah
that'll be my first that would be my
first one oh yeah
wow bro yeah that that audience is going
to flip for you i hope that'll be cool
dude that's so cool yeah i'm excited
about that
are you going to scotland as well yeah
glasgow glasgow that's right yeah yeah
it's probably the same run
yeah it probably is the first the first
time you did it was probably
it's got to be the same promoters
probably
but dude yeah we get well they let me
pick i think at edinburgh and glasgow
and i picked the glasgow it's just more
working class over there you know yeah
i'm doing like manchester yep leeds
glasgow
london and dublin damn yeah it'll be
cool then australia which yeah i've
never been over there how's that oh
the best do not come back and give
yourself an extra week over there bro i
i
i mean i was there for two weeks doing
shows but i should have taken like a
week and just stayed just yeah maybe i
will do that it's yeah because you it's
so hard to kind of get back over there
yeah i know that's not like i'm excited
about it but i'm already mad about the
flight yeah it's gonna suck
yeah well i think there's just a way to
manage it do you
do you have trouble with um
with the flying and traveling and stuff
you kind of okay i don't mind the fly
but i usually fly first now yeah i'm big
dude if i said coach i'm literally i
feel bad right because i like i'm i'm
the guy when you see me walking down the
[ __ ] aisle you're like please don't
sit next to me oh you know what i mean
yeah or at least in my head that's
all right probably right if i was
somebody and i saw me yeah big long
jacket don't you [ __ ] sit next to me
dude you're not gonna fit yeah
so i feel bad so i'm like i'm afraid to
touch the person next to me i sit like
this
for like four hours i'll have my
shoulder
yeah it sucks yeah i do that too i would
used to actually lace my arms under the
seat belt in front of me like this
that's probably put in both hands it's a
good way to keep them there yeah does he
keep them there and because i was
usually tired and i would i would be an
erratic sleeper like that and so i
didn't want to hit anybody while i was
while i was kind of laying there yeah i
was losing it yeah first class flights
to australia are like
20 000 is it really they're crazy
well i know i definitely noticed this
anything that's expensive is now
extremely more expensive like
inflation's gotten crazy
and um i think they're just billing
everything out the wazoo like even i
noticed now if you get like a suite at a
hotel like a regular room might be one
180 160. a suite now is like 900 you're
like yeah
it's just crazy i mean it's just i don't
know
it's a lot man yeah i hope it doesn't
continue to suck it would really blow if
we got into like for real hyperinflation
and like [ __ ] did go bad what could
happen would suck do you think you could
handle yourself do you have any
preparation like do you have any
i don't even i don't have a gun
i don't have yeah i live in [ __ ] new
york it's hard
can you have you can get a gun there
probably yeah probably maybe not
announced by the city i think yeah maybe
not even there anymore yeah
new york if [ __ ] started to go bad i'd
get the [ __ ] out of new york right that
wouldn't be that'd be
probably the last place in america i
would want to be or get on a ship dude
there's a lot of ships leaving out of
there ships would be good
people don't think about that
i asked somebody one time where would
you want to be if the world was falling
apart and they'd be like i'd be i'd get
on a ship and go like a couple hundred
yards off the coast like yeah great idea
then just come back in when you need
snacks yeah
or fish yeah it'd just be like your
vending machine
yeah what else was that nashville would
be good for that this would be a good
area for what [ __ ] started going pretty
bad
but you're centrally like so there's a
lot of people that can really attack you
yeah you know
i think anyway
um
has it been weird after uh
the cove it ended in new york has it
been weird has it been normal did you
find yourself missing the pandemic at
all yeah i missed the pandemic a lot i
left new york i was just at my parents
house a lot [ __ ] ruled i was down i was
down in the basement playing video games
i had an old xbox 360. the ncaa 14 on it
i played it for like six months oh yes
mom would make dinner
it was wonderful god that is nice it was
great and it was nice not [ __ ]
drinking every day it was nice hanging
out not going to bars just [ __ ]
sitting at home i mean i could do that
now but
yeah do you do uh i feel like i missed
it too i feel like i missed there was
less people on the roads oh that was the
best if you weren't scared of the panda
it was the best it was
dude i drove across the country at the
beginning of the pandemic it [ __ ]
ruled did y'all stay at campgrounds no i
just i went by myself i drove out to
[ __ ] stan hopes in arizona
it was the best
no one on the road gas was [ __ ] 30
cents
yeah what was it like going to stand
hopes is it pretty
it's wild it is yeah i was ready to go
back to my parents basement yeah i i i i
don't know it's fun they're the best
people on earth oh you're like the most
loving people
but
i was tired it's a lot you know i was a
guest i felt [ __ ] weird i was there
for like a month oh what yeah i
overstayed
pretty hard and were there any clues
that you should have left
no
yeah i was i was like i should leave i'm
gonna leave and they're like you don't
have to you don't have to this is fine
there's a guest house i was just there
oh dang was there a pool
no pool but it would get weird when i
wouldn't hang out
if i spent like a day or two just in the
guest house that was weird so then you
feel like you're gonna come out and
they'd be like does he [ __ ] hate us
oh like no i'm just hungover i'm not you
guys yeah i'm trying it's hard
and you're in the desert dude doing
partying or drinking anything in the day
it's like twice as hard on you yeah you
wake up it's just like oh i used to be
able to hear my eyes click open because
they were so dry when i'd be so
dehydrated out in the desert and it
would click open
um
what do you think about that elon musk
and twitter man i like it yeah what's
the hold up what's the hold up i don't
know
is it just cause he's gonna put trump on
uh oh is that you think that's what his
plan is i'm sure he would i think he's
gonna be like we need free speech i
think he's just gonna open the gates
it's gonna be kind of like that um yeah
like maybe he'll destroy twitter if he
does that i don't think he will i think
twitter will be [ __ ] nuts
you can do anything i know twitter if
twitter really you could do anything
because it's really it's an extremely
it's like an alt-left app basically yeah
it kind of is now it feels like anyway
maybe it's not
i don't i mean they
yeah i mean didn't they have like the
head of the taliban still on twitter oh
yeah trump was not yeah that's a good
point like
what are we doing and how much i wonder
how much like
hype they lost in the electron go
because trump was a [ __ ] i mean he's
as ridiculous as it was it was he
carried he carried it his now my
favorite thing is his old tweets yeah
you ever read those yeah it's so good
that's so good it's like robert
pattinson needs to leave that dog of a
woman she's going to cheat on him i know
it
it's just crazy he's talking about the
twilight kids
the best is when uh
bar still um dave portnoy interviewed
him and was like oh
yeah about the tweets and stuff do you
ever like kind of proofread it before
you put it out it was like you know
sometimes you kind of just rattle it off
and then you go to bed
he's just he was tweeting yeah that was
him
i was just down there i was just in
mar-a-lago oh i saw that picture did you
get to meet him no i saw him though he
was hanging out really and there was
like no one else there
and somebody was talking to me about his
tweets like they were with him
tweeting and he would just
sit there and be like
send it
just a [ __ ] storm immediately
50 articles immediately so crazy yeah
dude do you uh what was mar-a-lago like
was it uh real fancy it was extremely
fancy but it's small it's small it's not
as big as you'd think can you get a it's
a motel a hotel room ah no you can't you
gotta like get like
i had to get like clearance
yeah like the day before they had to get
like my name and all that [ __ ] wow yeah
cause i got some shows coming up in
florida i wonder if i could go there i
bet you could i bet you could it's crazy
there's like a guy with a machine gun at
the front door what like this is what is
it it i think it used to be
it's like a club you can join it it's
like 200 000 a year for membership and
there's like that there's no golf course
it's like a spa
and a restaurant oh wow and that's
that's about it that's two pools
yeah
and he just lives there basically
so that's the fun part you get to see
him walk around occasionally he plays
the music he plays yj's no he doesn't he
dj's the music at mar-a-lago
it's crazy and what kind of stuff does
he choose and is it like changing when i
was there it was hotel california yeah
which is crazy and that's also like the
most widest old dude song
and then it switched from like [ __ ] like
that and then it went to like proud to
be an american i swear to god and then
it would go back to that [ __ ]
i kind of it was like the beach boys
dude i'm surprised that more black dudes
didn't like trunk i think loki every
black dude kind of [ __ ] love trump i
think so
because i think that's a yeah
because he made
kodak black chills there yeah oh he
doesn't have mar-a-lago wow yeah
because he was all i mean in the end
he's kind of about [ __ ] and money
yeah that was it you know
yeah that's a good president yeah
it's like this guy the keys
see what he does
by far the most entertaining president i
don't know if being president even
matters anymore it feels like if you're
in politics now it almost feels like
it's just ridiculous to even be in it
yeah it is kind of embarrassing yeah you
look like a dork dude
yeah i guess it's not that important
because biden's clearly dead
oh i cannot like at a certain point it's
kind of not cool that we put a guy out
there who's not well dude it's kind of
sad yeah it's like mean right that's
what i feel like this is the only way we
can win is him right and it's like this
is kind of going to embarrass this he's
going to ruin his whole legacy well
every time he goes up there and speaks
you can just tell like you know you can
see an old guy when he's not doing real
help yeah you know it's fun to see him
when he's on though every once in a
while there's glimpses yeah oh [ __ ] he's
still got it yeah he's firing i've heard
he's a super nice guy man from people
from friends of mine that know him but
um i don't know i never i never knew a
lot of politicians every politician in
louisiana got busted for sex crimes or
embezzlement
that's good yeah that's who you want
you want someone that's like i'm taking
[ __ ] wild risks yeah i'm trying to
get it done
yeah that's true i think it's the only
real way to be i think you want like a
real
you want that jesse james in there yeah
do you i i why i kind of wish people
would start voting in insane just create
the wildest person you could think the
last two have been [ __ ] nuts that's
true trump was wild yeah biden's crazy
yeah these are two crazy picks yeah last
eight years we've had a leader that's
like
half you know half the country's like
dude what are we doing we've made some
wild chores we're like the cleveland
browns
just shuffling two quarterbacks first
round donald trump
god damn it he's a bust we're rolling
through [ __ ] it do you think he'll run
again
i don't know i think uh if he does
rob desantis won't run the guy from
florida right but then i think desantis
seems like desantis is gonna run yeah
and then who the [ __ ] are the democrats
going to go like who are they going to
pick i don't know
they're going to have to go with it they
did biden again
if they were like dude four more years
he's fine
he's just laying down somewhere yeah
like he's our guy
he's sharp as [ __ ] off camera he gets
nervous
they do need to try it's laughable but
they could [ __ ] laughable i hope they
get hillary
oh wow i hope they get hillary dude if
we get trump hillary oh again
i'll go crazy yes
look i was like i didn't vote for trump
i never voted i didn't vote for trump
this one i'd be like yeah trump's gotta
win
exciting dude yeah it'd be a good battle
oh i think it would be it would just be
so good to see them too because you see
them talking [ __ ] again oh
so good yeah
that's the kind of [ __ ] the best part i
wish that the vice pres the president
had to pick a vice president from the
other it had to be like
from the other part i always wish that
trump and bernie had to be on the same
ticket
because then it's like you have this
they're gonna have to figure [ __ ] out
you know you're gonna have to have some
real conversation what lincoln did with
his cabinet did he really yeah it was
there's a book called like team of
rivals he just got everybody disagreed
with oh yeah see you're
right there you're a better patriot than
i am
i mean i had an autograph hacksaw jim
duggan poster that's pretty good
that's honestly that's kind of more
patriotic
i don't know i mean he was a
construction worker but
i don't know if that's more
patriotic you know yeah but that's
something you like wrestling now
um not as much i mean i don't go watch
it no no have you been recently no well
soda took me to one like four years ago
yeah i'd never been to one it was
actually [ __ ] it's cool to see yeah
in person you're like holy [ __ ] this is
real it's a real production you guys are
getting [ __ ] up oh i saw a mexican
father and son and combined they were
probably eight four
and
they
were
it was when the rock came back there's a
night real rock came back it was like 10
years ago and they were when he came out
they were both standing there holding
hands bawling crying damn
and that's nice oh it was beautiful so i
was just saying i just saw i just
watched wrestlemania i haven't watched
wrestling in years yeah and
stone cold came out and i was instantly
just like holy [ __ ]
this is so sick yeah yeah i could i i'm
afraid i can't get into it
because that would be i don't need that
well you
what can you take on yeah i can't take
that personality on at this point yeah
it'd be bad there's no there's not a lot
of pros
now i will say this you remind me bring
up um
bring up the big boss man i think you
look a little bit like this guy people
bring that up for the big boss man son i
see that yeah i could bring it up there
if you look up big boss man
policeman wrestling yeah i do look like
the big boss man
but it's funny that we look through
things as a lens with racism because at
the time it didn't seem racist it's not
like we didn't know but black friends
wouldn't not watch wrestling it would be
like farouk would be out there the big
boss man would come out with a [ __ ]
stick a police dead yeah
i mean i think there's a circle yeah
[ __ ]
yeah i mean you don't want to play this
in minneapolis you don't want to play a
lot of big boss man reruns you know
there's certain places you want to do
stuff
the big boss man i don't know what he
would do yeah
um but yeah it's just fun yeah this is
fun and [ __ ] but yeah the old promos
like they'd have a [ __ ]
like an arab dude come out and be like
iran's the best america can suck on
[ __ ] dicks
see that's one thing i love about i love
it if a crown wants to change usa in
other countries you're allowed to have
so much more like this is our country
you know but here the media i feel like
you try to say yeah they've told us to
chill the [ __ ] out right our media tells
us we're the only ones doing that
totally other countries no i mean now
saying show the [ __ ] out but like other
countries are like
they're not we have flags everywhere and
everybody in america is like america's
the [ __ ] best or at least that's how
it used to be yeah that's how it used to
be yeah now it's a little more like
actually yeah we have a pretty troubled
history yeah like yeah go to [ __ ] any
other country dude
yeah look into anybody's history
everyone's saying it not you know not
saying it doesn't matter but yeah
they're all a little dicey yeah well
being a lot of existence has been a
dicey run yeah it's been pretty bad yeah
um
i think you know i don't know
i mean i just you know i do my best did
you ever do opium in them show
no by the time
no i was i was i was late i did anthony
akumi's show i did
jim and sam [ __ ] like that oh yeah jimmy
yeah yeah that's a bummer i've seen you
go on there it was fun on there yeah it
was wild on there yeah dude i had so
much fun in there just sitting goofing
around
i just felt like such a just uh it just
felt like a real goof game and that's
what it was also nice back then when
you'd be exciting to be on a [ __ ] you'd
be like holy [ __ ] i'm gonna do siriusxm
today yeah [ __ ] crazy yeah now if i
know if it's like a [ __ ] i get it
gotta get into this podcast [ __ ]
radio yeah oh the radio yeah yeah the
radio really really it's sometimes over
the road when i was just starting i was
like damn so sick okay i gotta do radio
not a big deal
like we're going with the radio station
doing it yeah
i'm not doing it dude it must be crazy a
lot of comedy i guess i haven't gone
into morning radio in a long time
thank god i mean it's a blessing not to
have to go but remember how hectic it
was if you got into a place you get on
the late flight sometimes yeah or you
get the early flight you get there you
have to go straight to the radio station
and then you got to try and get a nap in
after that which is five am it's almost
[ __ ] six am radio
and you go in and they don't care at all
half they like so what was snl like
every now and then in florida they would
care florida
yeah yeah yeah yeah florida still loves
their radio
um yeah yeah and they had rochester new
york had a good radio station
there's still some markets that were
pretty sick yeah but it was different
man i just hated waking up yeah so hard
did you ever uh
i remember getting so drunk one night i
peed all over my phone it was like when
cell phones first came out and i [ __ ]
missed it
and they were fury oh really people were
so pissed yeah what do they
it's okay
it was bad
oh
it was a day where i was supposed to
drive myself over there
oh okay so that was the thing
i got to do one rogan show and i didn't
know that i was gonna go up first right
so we're just standing there backstage
and he's like you guys ready to start
the show and we're like yeah and i just
been kind of like getting busier you
know and so like i think i was probably
somewhere in my head i'm getting a
little bit full of myself or something
you know and so then he just gets on the
mic and i i just assume that somebody
else is there to go first and then he's
like ladies and gentlemen
and i walk out there and i'm like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's like 3 000 people most
people i've ever been in front of people
are still sitting down and i'm like oh
jesus yeah and part of the lights they
were still on for some reason it was
just no oh it was so hard man it was so
hard that was fun though that was a
nightmare bro i mean it was awesome yeah
and it was super cool but it was just
hard yeah that sucks i've had to do that
a couple times yeah where like you're on
the road with someone big and they're
like all right you go first
of course and then you get off stage
like [ __ ] i should have killed right but
people were literally sitting down
and they they hated me yeah oh that was
the feeling i had [ __ ] off the stage oh
dude i wanted to get out of it and then
i don't even want to get out of the
place you want to get out of the whole
city you want to get out off the tour
you want to get off of the earth
when it goes real bad was it um was it
was working with louie pretty cool yeah
it was awesome
that was like a dream did he approach
you about it yeah wow yeah it was cool
he saw me perform at the cellar one
night and he was like laughing and i was
like damn that's crazy and then like two
days later i got an email from his lady
that was like do you want to come work
on the tour i was like yes
i was pumped was it when you were
was it did you feel real inferior with
his comedy because his comedy's so
unique and good it's uh sometimes i'll
watch and i'm like oh man yeah for sure
i mean but he's one of those like
he's so good that i'm not even comparing
you know what i mean right like if it
was
somebody like our age and they were
murdering and i wasn't even close i'd be
like [ __ ] i actually i don't
like them now yeah like something crazy
like that yeah yeah and that but with
with him it was like yeah he's i think
he's the best ever so yeah i didn't yeah
it was cool to watch yeah he is he i
mean he's just
man he's so good i just watched he just
ran his
i was with him he ran his new hour for
the first time after his special
i was with him the night he ran and he
was like it's funny because he was like
nervous he's like writing and like how
do i
killed first time he ever ran it damn
that was when i was sitting in the back
like [ __ ] i'm not even close he hadn't
even ever practiced it
he'd run it he had definitely done like
spots but it was the first time we ran
it all together yeah
someone said that he made and this is a
rumor that i heard 13 million dollars on
a special selling it online yeah
probably i believe that
i wonder if that's true or not i believe
it's probably what like 10 bucks 20
bucks yeah that's what i thought yeah
because how many people have to buy it
then
a million
oh yeah good call
yeah
yeah something like that because i
remember asking my agent about it he's
like no [ __ ] way you know yeah but
but the agents want you to think that
because they want you to sell your
special to uh um
to a also he was running ads did you see
any of those uh-uh louis was running
like he bought ad space on tv i was
running infomercials that's amazing for
the special good for him or like funny
yeah damn he's so creative yeah
um do you find it easier as you got more
popular do you feel like it's gotten
easier do you feel like it's gotten more
complicated has anything changed for you
you think as far as i think
stand-up-wise it's definitely it's
easier which is kind of a problem right
you know what i mean right like people
just like to see you so it's not even
about what you're doing
yeah this bit sucked
and they're like
yeah there's something about the element
of surprise yeah
yeah
there's something about being surprising
um
did they have a lot of uh i'm trying to
think of something that could have
happened when you're young oh do you
remember the first man you ever saw that
could have been homosexual or anything
like that and you guys were kind of
shocked by it
i guess we i didn't know because it was
priests
i knew something was weird i just
figured it was because he was a priest
oh he like spoke with an effeminate
voice oh dang i remember being a kid and
being like maybe it's just cause he's a
priest he's
different
oh yeah like god loves him so much that
he just has so much love in him that
some of it's coming out towards men
or more of it than usual
yeah yeah i think that was it how about
you the first guy you saw you're like
damn definitely
well we had a mentally handicapped guy
in our town and uh
people would be like that guy's gay you
know and he wasn't he's mentally
handicapped but nobody knew because he
rode like a woman's bicycle
and so
uh
people were always yelling gay adam and
stuff like that
but he was just like handicapped you
know and he would kind of come by the
school a lot but i think it was he was
like child minded yeah so he would just
try to be by the school and stuff like
that and be friends with other boys and
he wasn't gay at all he was just
his genetics were gay
you know he was straight but he was just
mentally unwell i had two guys like one
guy he used to ride a tricycle around he
was sick he had a tricycle with his a
customized license plate on the front
with his name on it wasn't even trying
to get it was john
he would try to get you
he would come up and be like you do you
like pancakes oh you'd be like yeah yeah
you want to put pancakes in my pants and
be like dude john what are you doing
i didn't even i wasn't even afraid as a
kid i'm gonna use that like i was just
like
this guy's wild i didn't even think that
it was like he was trying to rape
but i don't know if he was i don't think
he was i think he was just having fun
breakfast saying wild stuff yeah yeah i
don't want to put that on his name i
think he was just riding his trike
around talking [ __ ] to people
which is a pretty good life oh dude i
think yeah if you're living like that i
think living lore it's definitely one
way to go getting a tricked out tricycle
yeah if you're a mentally handicapped
man someone hooks you up with that yeah
and then you just get to ride around say
whatever you want to like kids oh yeah
no one had a problem oh go after kids
and they'd be like
that's john dude he's wild yeah he's
wild remember that before everything was
before everybody was a creep it was like
that guy was wow wow he has a good time
yeah he's riding around a tricycle
through a neighborhood
um yeah i'm trying to think if we had
like a guy i mean we had some pedos and
stuff as i got a little bit over alleged
guys you know yeah um
i always i always give it pass to the
mentally handicapped pedos
i mean yeah i can't be mad at them well
i'm sure there's and i've heard of this
um that there's a lot of guys who would
let
mentally handicapped guys jack them off
or do you know do sexual stuff that's
not great yeah
no but to like oh oh for them to get it
out no for them like the guy wanted to
so it's like
to help him you know i hate to say to
help him out but it's like
yeah
you know the guy wants to so bad and you
are trying to help the mentally unwell i
guess now that i say it out loud it
sounds funny yeah wait crazy that's
totally crazy
someone was like
hold on someone was like i think this
mentally handicapped guy's horny i'll
take care of it guys
no
i'm gonna let him masturbate me yeah
yeah
yeah that's crazy [ __ ] man
[ __ ] people are [ __ ] up
i didn't even think about that i always
thought like yeah man i totally see what
you're saying
but now that i really put it on you know
put pen to paper it's pretty bad here's
a question that came in right here
hey theo hey shane gang gang was
wondering what you guys thought about
taxidermy i got my impala right there
and then got my ram head right here ram
head that's the baphomet from uh matt
shane you can talk him into getting one
uh you guys down for it bringing the
outdoors indoors and uh what kind of
taxidermy would you guys like good
question man you know a lot of uh you
see in the urban community they do a lot
of human taxidermy you've seen that
recently a lot of that stuff's been put
out there like a brother at you know him
standing by the door at his own at his
funeral yeah yeah that's awesome it's
just pretty live putting a blunt in his
[ __ ] hand yeah everyone yeah it's a
good way black people do pretty dope
[ __ ] like that like black people are
hella fearless i think when it comes to
death white people are a lot more like
traditional with it i think yeah and
black people sometimes will get a lot
more
uh avant-garde sure
um those african funerals
dudes are holding the casket like
dancing and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] so hype
decent way to go [ __ ] isn't wasn't new
orleans pretty cool about it oh yeah
they have like parades and [ __ ] yeah
they got good second line parades and
stuff like that for weddings and
funerals you know people will come out
and celebrate you can hire these guys
and they'll come out and play and
and everybody kind of gets these towels
and you dance a little bit it's got a
real that's actually one of the funnest
things especially if it's at a wedding
you're rolling through the french
quarter and everybody's just letting it
go
and you're just like uh
yeah it's a really good time man marbles
are in their tuxedos cruising to answer
that guy's question the my girlfriend
her dad
haunts like crazy like african animals
so he's got like a taxidermy room of
like all that [ __ ] like the impala and
all that and we're gonna i'm gonna get
him
i bet he's gonna give us two if he
passes away no he's giving him he's
mailing them oh wow do you get to pick
them out of you you already picked them
out i think they're ones he didn't like
but they're awesome
you know so you have two of those in my
apartment wow that's pretty cool you're
excited about it yeah it is nice yeah
well i'm trying to think i almost bought
a buffalo not long ago i was priced out
the man i thought was price gouging it
but it was a buffalo head that's all
yeah we'll see i think i bet it's still
there i thought about driving by but um
but that's something i thought about
wait he's got it it's in a store it's in
a store yeah oh yeah you notice
different gloves as you get older yeah
definitely
like the first time you fall in love
it's like crazy
i was in college i was like yeah i was
such a [ __ ] weirdo i was like
emailing
i was like emailing her she would get in
a fight i'd be at work after i'd be like
you [ __ ] oh yeah sending like
crazy yeah
oh yes because email was like it was
almost like a text message back then
yeah there was no and i'd have to check
my emails
see if she got back oh she didn't
send another email
yeah
about you are you in love
no i'm not in love i i've definitely
have been in love
um
i would like to be in love again yeah
you know i think it definitely gets
different it gets different when you're
young that young love
man do you ever buy flowers for a girl
anything like that did you ever do any
crazy stuff like in front of a group of
people you're like dang that dude must
be in love trying to think
i went to a basketball game once and
like gave a flower to a girl at the game
like when she was in the stands
and it was like people were yelling
you know people were yelling the n word
dude i think i'd be on your ass like it
was like i saw a dude do it yeah even
though i i have done it yeah yeah
if i saw someone else giving a flower to
a girl i'd be like
[ __ ] yeah it'd be so fun
i think i really like [ __ ]
yeah it got soft
bro it was so crazy and i had so much
acne at the time i was afraid to move my
face because i thought a lot of the acne
would pop
that's crazy oh
how'd it go with the flower did she like
it it went fine man i feel like it
doesn't work like anytime you go crazy
like that and like try to do an
over-the-top romantic thing
with a girl you're not dating oh yeah
like if you're like i want to date you i
got you this
bouquet yeah it's like enough
she's not indian oh dude they had uh
iron we used to work with this one guy
named thomas and he sent this girl like
the biggest cinnamon cake ever and i'm
like what is a cinnamon cake first of
all and i'm a risk
oh
and she thought he was insane yeah she
he sent it to a bar she worked at so she
gets to her bar shift and there's a huge
like somebody sent you this do you know
thomas yeah she's like barely
you got me a cake
uh he has to sit there waiting like yeah
i wonder how this is going he's probably
loving that [ __ ] cake
he just gets a text like never call me
again
[ __ ]
sitting back launching a cake and
sitting back and be like
this is gonna go
well and then never hearing from the
woman again
just drop it you forget about it and now
you can't even go to the bar anymore oh
never again that's the craziest
that bar's gone yeah you got to burn it
down
you got to go that night and set fire to
it
oh man i'm trying to think of anything
of another time i wrote a poem to a girl
once oh definitely in like seventh grade
yes here's this is the worst part this
is like this is one of the most
embarrassing things i've ever done yeah
i it keeps me up at night today
uh
i wrote a bible verse on the back of it
and gave it to her and my friends found
it before she got it or she got it and
gave it to my friends it was like look
how weird this dude is
i walked into school the next day and my
buddy was holding it
and i was like dude
i'll fight you
teary eyed i was like don't don't show
that to anyone
and you already had of course of course
disaster bro a bible verse
which one was you remember yeah it was
uh
[ __ ] it's so bad it was like song of
songs it's like a love book oh yeah it's
a book of the bible that's about like
people falling in love yeah
that dude sixth grade i was like i love
god
yeah i loved being catholic in sixth
grade god is my greatest dude yeah that
guy i remember that guy had a shirt took
a lot for me to tell you that
oh dude i'll tell you i used to steal a
[ __ ] child's bike from my neighbor's
yard
and i would bike over to this girl's
house it was like four miles right yeah
in the middle of the night
to go over there and like
just kind of suck on our breasts for a
while that's [ __ ] great yeah but then
i have to bike all the way back bro it
would take i'll do that today dude
like four miles to suck tits
pretty crazy my story your story was
awesome oh yeah my story was the most
embarrassing thing i've ever done
you rode a bike to suck tits yeah that
shit's awesome how old were you
uh you were young that shit's awesome oh
uh no well uh
i was probably yes 15
15. bro
that's as good as it gets yeah god and
those tits were good back then yeah
remember how good a tip child
if you were a child yeah of course
child on child tits
what was that dude right when they got
tits you were you were like dude she's
got the biggest hits in the class she's
ore
dude that [ __ ] with the huge kids
oh look you have no idea what being a
[ __ ] was you're like just whoever has
the biggest hits is a [ __ ] oh i
remember i called my bus driver at dildo
i heard the term and i didn't know what
it was yeah gear's such a dildo
and then i had to go to the principal's
office and the principal beat us that's
back when they used to beat you you know
oh yeah they probably kept that going in
louisiana for a while right i think they
stretched it out they went a little late
they got to like the obama
administration
extra innings on that but i remember
going to the principal's office man and
he would freaking rat he oh he'd rattle
he he had that big
paddles yeah i remember the principles
had paddles yeah
it's what gave it's what gave them a lot
of their power too yeah i felt like now
they're [ __ ]
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do yeah i'm italian they don't have any
real power nothing
that's awesome i mean
i can see how that worked yeah having a
[ __ ] stick behind your desk
threatening to hit a child did y'all
have different like clicks and stuff at
y'all school
yeah for sure
yeah
regular clicks although it was a
catholic school so you couldn't we had a
uniform so it's hard to really
express yourself yeah but the goss found
their way yeah they hit you with like
some eyeliner or something yeah yeah but
yeah everybody's wearing the same
[ __ ] thing oh i actually liked it
yeah i mean i i i hated having to have
clothes jersey for three days yeah it's
all i did see it before
i was it was the first time i wore it
last time oh good and i've never i've
wanted to wear a jersey for a long time
and you did and now i'm doing it yeah
i'm glad you did i'm over doing it
though oh dude i'll tell you this one
night so i talked about this this girl i
met at a coffee shop who i tried to like
it got so embarrassing and i ordered
this omelet or whatever and then i'd
still sit there and eat it even though
like i had like
i tried to ask her out but i think i
didn't get the words right and she said
something and i couldn't even hear it
and then i got nervous and just walked
away and so then i'm just sitting there
with this omelette and i had
and i and the just
just the pain of just sitting there
eating the omelette and it's just me and
not hungry at all just getting rid of it
the only reason i went there was to talk
to her and i couldn't do it all right
anyway the next time i go back in there
was like three months later um after
everybody had eaten the cinnamon cake
and uh she uh
she's like oh my gosh people called here
and uh and even called my boss
so [ __ ] and i was like wow that's crazy
that's awesome though yeah like they're
like you never should have divorced the
rat king that's what they say i'm like
divorced
yeah it's crazy that's pretty hype dude
that's wild
um
well [ __ ] man i know you got a tour
going on yeah you know i don't want to
keep this thing alive any longer than it
is it feels like bro
i'm so i feel bad bro
dude congrats on all your success man
and where can people if they haven't
seen your tour they want to come see you
uh
shanemgilis.com okay yeah excellent yeah
go check out shane if you haven't seen
him um
you know
there's just nothing like him i think
there's nothing like watching somebody
who's having so much fun
uh and that's what i notice when i'm
watching you man and uh yeah thanks for
coming and hanging out man i appreciate
it you're the man baby
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
[Music]
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself go
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load
[Music]
now